wooden chairs cost the hydrants $32 to
make hit pause right there this amount
of money obviously it's important but
there's going to be a few different you
know numbers here so I want to actually
state $172 means not just write down
$170 look at the sentence again it says
wooden chairs costs a hundred and
seventy two dollars to make so I'm gonna
call this cost price so rather than just
write down a number and then in my
working it's like what does this number
me what does it stand for if I'm reading
you're working what what kind of
thinking process do I see going on here
I'd love you to write with me what this
quantity actually stands for that's what
it is cost price equals hundred seventy
dollars that should be your first line
of working and then it goes on calculate
the selling price here's the next piece
of working right if the chairs are
marked up by thirty five percent when
sold quick question why do they mark it
up like that's how much it costs to make
why do they sell it for more Harry I
can't humble one so they can make a
profit number two there might be other
associated costs that are not to say of
a cost price like staff that kind of
thing rent all of that so we're going to
try and work out selling price now
there's two different ways we can do
this and I'm gonna show you the two ways
of working out right now okay Mirek okay
so let's let's take Marek's first idea
before i take his calculation I want to
know what it is he's working out that's
the mark-up is what he's calculating so
let's do let's take Marik's suggestion
the first thing is to write down its our
first way of solving it is to calculate
the mark-up it's 35 percent of this 172
just like before what operation is that
off you see that's x so I'm gonna write
x and then here's my 172 dollars okay
now these are weird numbers I don't have
my own 35 times tables off the top of my
head so it someone like to punch into
their calculator what 35 percent times a
hundred seventy two years earlier say it
again sixty point sixty point two now
I'm just going to write down Sanders
as you stated to me David thank you
this might be what your calculator
display says but I want to interpret
this in the light of the question 60
point - what is it an amount of it's an
amount of it's money it's dollars right
so I'm gonna put the unit at the front
and I don't tend to write like sixty
point two dollars I would really usually
write sixty dollars and 20 cents so I'll
put a zero on the end there to indicate
that I know I'm talking about now what
am I gonna do with this what's the thing
I want to calculate what's the name of
it don't tell me the numbers tell me the
name of it have a look
selling price thank you very much yes
it's really important not just to have
numbers and equations flying around and
symbols I want to know what they stand
for right how am I going to take the
numbers I've got on the page and combine
them yes Mary okay I'm gonna add them
together cos price plus my markup
that'll be our selling price and we can
write that down firstly and then we can
calculate it now I don't thinking we
even need a calculator for this do we
can do this in our heads it's gonna
start with a two three three two hundred
and thirty two and twenty cents and if
you really want you can verify that on
your calculator okay
so this means of working it out perfect
I have my odd set down there but there
is another way whoops I will put on line
unintentionally through my zeros there
is another way that can actually go
straight to the final line without doing
quite so much working but we have to
think a little more to get there right
so here's what I'm gonna write instead
I'm going to try to do the markup and
the selling price in one hit takes a bit
more thinking but you've got to lay it
out carefully I'm gonna go straight to
my selling price and here's how I'm
going to write it in Marik's working out
which i think is perfect by the way you
notice you've got 100% of the cost price
here and thirty-five percent of the cost
price here let me say that again in fact
I'm gonna write it because so important
you've got 100 percent of the cost price
there and thirty
percent of the cost price there now have
a big what's the total percentage if you
put those together that the selling
price is Jessica one hundred and thirty
five percent you see where we got that
from your adding them together just like
you added here okay yep okay yes real
quick cuz the bells gone 135 percent is
the total percentage and I multiply that
by the original cost price and you'll
get the same answer
exactly